with the 2020 Iowa caucus just four days
away campaign staff circuits and
reporters are pouring into the state and
it is estimated get this that they will
spend more than eleven million dollars
in the state capital des moines alone in
the week before the caucuses now the
number of people flying through the city
jumped about seven percent in December
compared to the same month in 2018 when
there was no caucus it'll keep us in Des
Moines for us this morning
heed good morning you're there spending
some of CBS's money in that local
economy
what's the broader impact of all this
attention the state's getting well good
morning again Tony the greatest boost
perhaps is to the state's image remember
this is a state heavily reliant on
agriculture but every four years the
rest of the country is reminded Iowa's
about much more than just corn and pork
production and all the money generated
by us and the candidates who come to the
state certainly helps you know every
four years democracy begins here in Iowa
presidential hopefuls all but moved to
this small but influential Midwestern
state investing resources we went up by
knocking on doors all across Iowa time I
just finished going to every one of the
99 counties in Iowa and money
I hope you've seen the TV as we're
spending a fortune on the TV for Iowa
it's like the dork Olympics in 2016
Hillary Clinton helped Mike Draper's
three Reagan t-shirt shops become must
stop destinations for Democratic
candidates when Bernie came in he got a
picture taken with his I rode the van
bill shirt he was like you selling these
shirts well yeah there's something kind
of a lot of them he's like but how many
and I was like whoa bro are you going to
percentage now it's like so much for
socialism give us a sense of what
business would be like in a normal
January hard to determine exactly when
the best time to come to Iowa is but
it's not late January which means the
caucus is this enormous surge it January
will be up 25% over a normal January
from the caucuses that's roughly the
same bump in business seen by Carter
printing which has been owned by Scott
Hoyts family for four generations for us
is probably 25 to 30% of our business
yeah it's it's always a nice bump I
think it helps us just fill in the gaps
especially when it's slow
in the wintertime Hoyts Union run shop
has been printing campaign material for
Democratic candidates since the 1980s
brochures Flyers yard signs stuff like
that lapel stickers buttons if you're
running for president as a Democrat in
Iowa right now they're probably printing
with you guys more than likely yes must
have been a pretty good year it was a
pretty good year yeah we did a little
bit for about 80% of the candidates Wow
hotels like this one in downtown Des
Moines are likely sold out leading up to
the caucus according to Greg Edwards CEO
of the Convention and Visitors Bureau
the last caucus compared to the previous
year for that week in hotel occupancy
jumped over 13% just for that week so
it's got huge huge economic impact it's
a really little drop in the bucket Iowa
State University economist Dave Swenson
found during the 2008 campaign major
candidates spent more than 350 million
dollars in the run-up to the caucus but
just four percent of that went to Iowa
that's around fifteen million dollars in
a state economy of more than 130 billion
it's perhaps comparable to hosting the
NCAA regional tournament if corn and
soybean prices go up or down
the value of those kinds of changes
dwarfed the value of the caucuses
so visitor spending is focused mostly on
big cities like here in Des Moines
everyone we spoke to agree that perhaps
the biggest benefit is the free PR the
local Convention and Visitors Bureau
estimates that last year about 200
million dollars in free advertising was
generated by all the news coverage from
across Iowa and guys we're here in
Raygun this morning while we were here I
did a little shopping and I got you into
a little gift from here in Iowa so they
make funny shirts all about the campaign
tawny Americans for America needs
journalists what Anthony yes
Iowa for some reason you have to come
here to be president Gale yes someone in
Iowa loves me one for you
I like all of those that it's been my
experience that free PR is never a bad
thing free good PR is happy we'll be
right back